happy fourth of July American friends
and happy random Jane July to everybody
else enjoy your festivities safely and
consume a moderate amount of gaming news
is that it some thought you guys were
super keen on the resident evil 7 demo
Capcom have revealed that it was
downloaded more than 2 million times in
its first week of release despite only
being available to PlayStation Plus
subscribers resident evil 7 beginning
our has proved to be extremely popular
the demo is a prologue and won't be part
of the full rosy seven game which will
feature a different protagonist and is
due out on ps4 xbox one and pc on
january 24 of next year we have once
again been told that this time the game
will return to its horror roots it will
also be playable from start to finish
easy playstation vr l build once closed
alpha has been data mines revealing a
whole bunch of game info in the words of
Reddit user lo bix who leaked the
information EA and dice I'm sorry the
lake suggests the battlefield one single
player campaign will have 20 chapters
spread across seven episodes including a
prologue and epilogue you'll get special
dog tags for completing road to
Battlefield one mission in battlefield 4
or hard line and they will also be given
to those that own an existing
battlefield game attend a battlefield
one event or participate in the pound
filled one beta the post also suggests
there will be over 30 weapons ranging
from handguns two boats and cavalry
weapons as well as a slew of gadgets
including mines ammo crates gas masks
and flare guns if you want all the
spoilery details you can also find a
list of maps melee weapons game modes
and more in our story on gamespot
battlefield one is due out on October 21
finally there's been some controversy
surrounding the ownership of Cisco lotto
com a counter strike global offensive
weapon skin gambling site it turns out
the site is owned by YouTube stars team
Martin and post syndicate real names
Trevor Martin and Tom passel who
supposedly did not disclose their
ownership of the site while promoting it
both youtube celebs and posted videos
where they gamble counter strike weapon
skins using the websites are shown
winning a lot of money and yes that does
sound super sucks csgo lotto lets
players add weapon skins to a pot and
then via the means of a random number
generator one player is awarded the pot
skins are assigned a real money value
within steams marketplace based on
rarity and are designed to be bought
sold and traded these kinds of
third-party services let you cash weapon
skins out and earn real money and
according to a Bloomberg report as much
as 2.3 billion dollars worth of skins
were bet during the last year alone
another side of the problem is that skin
gambling isn't regulated in the same way
traditional gambling is so given the
audience of these videos tends to skew
towards younger people underage gambling
is a very real possibility the youtubers
have said they never hid the fact they
earned the site although a YouTube video
by h3h3 Productions has dated that a
team of researchers have thus far not
been able to find any evidence that
either Martin or Castle disclosed their
ownership of the site in that earlier
videos as the pair suggest just weeks
ago a lawsuit was filed against valve
which reported that they knowingly
allowed an illegal online gambling
market to develop through csgo skin
gambling valve takes a five percent cut
every time an item assault on their
marketplace and could likely be making
hundreds of millions of dollars from
item trading let me know what you think
of this one in that comment box you
should a visit game Squatch what we've
got
stories on watch dogs too and overwatch
and come back again tomorrow for a bunch
more gaming news